esto es uno de los principales centros
de votación en cascais y pese a lo que
decían todos los sondeos de una
abstención cercana al 60% pues se ha
visto totalmente lo contrario una
afluencia de votantes en prácticamente
todos los centros de votación tanto en
el centro como en interior del país
incluso también en madeira me permito
mostrar las imágenes las filas de las
personas a la espera para ejercer el
derecho al voto esta ha sido una
constante es bastante rápido el proceso
las personas guardan distanciamientos
sin embargo tardan entre 15 y 20 minutos
en poder ejercer su derecho al voto
también todas las encuestas apuntan como
lo decías a que marcelo reveló de souza
gane en la reelección sin embargo para
esto tendrá que obtener el 50% de los
votos de lo contrario sin ningún
candidato le obtiene habrá una segunda
vuelta el próximo 14 de febrero
básicamente en todo el país se ha
registrado unas elecciones en calma y
con alta afluencia sin embargo ha visto
han habido algunas incidencias por
ejemplo en uno de los centros de
votación en aveiro un grupo de personas
protestó para cerrar un centro de
votación
porque en esas frases y as hacen falta
médicos y considera un respeto que haya
elecciones pero no haya atención
suficiente en los hospitales
muy bien daniela y estas elecciones se
producen a pesar de que el país está
gravemente afectado por la pandemia de
kobe 19 qué medidas se han tomado para
garantizar la seguridad de los votantes
y cuéntanos cuál es la situación general
en portugal
si es bastante de crítica la situación
en portugal se habla de más de 1000
personas fallecidas en los últimos cinco
días las emergencias y los cuidados
intensivos en los hospitales
prácticamente colapsados la medida que
ha tomado el gobierno para garantizar la
seguridad de los ciudadanos y que salgan
a votar es que ese obligatorio el uso de
las máscaras que cada persona tenga que
traer su bolígrafo para poder ejercer el
derecho al voto que se cumple el
distanciamiento y han colocado más mesas
de votación menos electores por mesa más
centros de votación en todo el país
también que se desinfecten las manos
cada vez que vayan a ingresar y esto es
básicamente el llamado que hacen a la
ciudadanía de hecho como decías salir a
votar es prácticamente una de las únicas
excepciones este fin de semana para
poder salir de casa